when I got in the business like most
people I think I did a lot of the type
from home and the selling doors so like
I get it like we getting cuz like we
want the money and you started going
after that that's what the initial draw
a lot of times is is like I need to make
some money and after making money really
quickly your eyes how unfulfilling that
is and you're like ah that was not that
cool and then and then you start seeing
the success of the people that you're
whatever you're selling to the people
and then like that becomes this next
level of when we're like oh my gosh like
because I did something cool like that
person had this big win and that becomes
this drug that's like like at least for
me it's unquenchable I could just keep I
keep wanting I desire like the more
happens the more I want it and the more
and so for me like that's this thing and
so when when things would struggle I
remember I remember I like I use boxers
like my my motive of communication with
most of the world so it's just a little
walkie-talkie app and an inbox err you
can if the message is really cool we put
a little star next to it so my kids had
a cute thing I'll put a star next to it
when people my friends or clients or
customers sent testimonials I put a star
next to it so then you can go listen to
all the stars you want and so like when
times were down I'd go back and I just
go listen I click on the star section
and listen and I just listened to like
30 40 minutes that people tell me how I
changed the life what happened how it
worked and was just like all right and
like listening to that got me back this
spot of like okay I got to do this and
then my favorite my favorite quote of
all time is Churchill however long in
heart of the road and he's talking to
you know to the to Parliament about this
this war they'd have to go on it's gonna
be brutal all these things how hard it's
gonna be in and then the variance says
like we're gonna you know victory a
victory at all cost victory however long
and hard the road and so whenever I
listen that Rick reset on myself like
this is where we got to go and then it's
like all right we're going victory
however long are the road whatever it's
got to go where we got to do we're just
gonna go and we're gonna go and we're
gonna go and that that phrase like
however long hard the road like rings
through my head all the time every time
I'm tired or I'm frustrated I think
about the people I hear about success
and then and then we'd go after it and
that's kind of the draw for me the pole
one thing that's interesting about
Churchill that I think is very apropos
of the moment that we're in is he not
long after the war they ousted him and
he was the right man at that time who
rose up
was exactly what that country needed and
look if people are willing to reach
within themselves like this is a time
for people that are willing to step up
and shine this is a huge opportunity how
do you think about that like it it would
be very easy to see this time as you
know just a time to suffer and get
through like when you were cutting
weight or do you think that you know
there is a way to reframe this is
opportunity I think this is the grace I
mean I'm a turn 40 this year this is the
greatest opportunity in the four decades
I've ever been on serve like in the UI
right now people are scared there's fear
and the people who everyone's looking to
be led like their like everyone's just
freaked out even people who are leaders
are like trying to find people to lead
them right like everyone's everyone's
struggling I think the people that are
willing to stand up and raise their
hands and say look I'm gonna lead come
follow me now is like the the time and I
always tell people like my I have a big
belief that like the business isn't just
like a way we make money or way we waste
our time like I believe the businesses
are calling from God and I was telling
you like you've been called to serve a
group of people and like now you've been
called if you've ever held that tug
before like they my friend Alex sharpen
calls with a call contribution like you
feel this this this tug this pull like
you've been called and there's a group
of people that you have been called to
serve that you can change their life but
you've got to be willing to like do the
things to like step up and like there's
so many fear I think that the tons of
people are called but most people don't
ever step up to and they they shrink
back down but those who are willing to
step up to that calling and say alright
my job I got a gather group of people
and with my gifts my talents I'm gonna
serve these people to the best of my
ability man on the other side of this
they're gonna be ones that have the
companies that have the brands that have
these things especially right now like
yeah we're giving like it's it's such a
double-edged sword like there's there's
all this fear was also blessed me right
now you look it add cost like I don't
know what you guys just need are add
costs have dropped dramatically like we
went from spending four or five dollars
for webinar register and trying our pain
78 cents we had 17,000 17,000 people
register for webinar I have tonight
17,000 like people are so cheap they're
looking they're begging they're they're
trying to find things I saw an article
from Facebook saying that they're gonna
lose forty billion dollars over the next
couple months because AD knows buying
ads and so we're coming in and like
man outside we can gather people at a
cost that's unheard of like they always
tell like I should go back when Google
is easy back you know 17 years ago I got
started like it just happened like like
three or four weeks ago I get it opened
up the odd cos dropped it's like I can
gather people the cost now I never could
before and so I think you know on the
other side of this wasn't people who
missed this opportunity others who were
like look I jumped on and I found a
group I've called to serve them I'm
serving them and doing everything my
ability I'm gathering these people
together and and when others you know on
the other side of this man people are
gonna remember who was it was the person
that got me through the hard times who's
the person that gave me the hope in a
brighter future like those the people
they connect with and they're gonna keep
following for for forever and so I think
now such a unique awesome time and and
and we can get attention from so many
people such a discount it's just it's a
good time for them to start to start
step it up and start publishing and
start putting your voice out there yeah
no question man how do i aggressively
agree with that i'm compliant this is
the mask is the best money can buy you
know I got it from Donald Trump it's the
best it's always the best
I'm just want to show you that I'm
compliant although I think this whole
cold that night thing thing was both
well anyway I'm compliant and social
distancing I'm doing all that but now
that you see this I can begin I don't
like to put my money and it's not a
gambler I just don't like to gamble so I
would prefer the studying and learn and
then invest you know for example is when
I came back from Vietnam in 1973 I
wanted to learn to invest in real estate
I asked my rich dad he would teach me
and he says no he says that's not his
job so I took real estate courses and I
still take real estate courses I make
fortunes in real estate but most people
are gamblers you know they they think
they can walk on water and they can just
buy something in there Donald Trump next
week or something but even Donald Trump
started really really small you know you
know you know I've been friends for
about eight or eight years working
together
he started off the same way I kind of
did you know working with his dad and
learning how to construct and build and
there's a lot of education goes into
real estate and then for him to build it
huge high rises today in mega projects
that you still start small if you're
stupid you're not going to make any
money anyway
you know I I've talked to so many people
who during that period of 2008 till
today they did nothing and you could
have made fortunes in that time and paid
no taxes if you had real financial
education but unfortunately as you know
most people go to school to get a job or
a card save money get out of debt an
investable long-term a well-diversified
portfolio stocks bonds major fronting
etf and that's what they're broke today
see our schools are criminal operations
you know they you know many young people
are going to school today on these
student loans which also came out in
2009 the same year that Bitcoin was
invented what happened in 2009 was Obama
went to the bank that said hey give the
kids all the money they want the US
government will back up your loans so if
you as a young person take out a loan
let's say for $100,000 and you don't pay
it off well you're trashed because
you'll have a bad you know credit score
for the rest of your life but the bank's
off the hook because the Fed will give
them the money and that's what's
happening right now and so that's why
you know I says it's criminal what the
education system is doing by not
teaching anybody anything about money
this is not that hard to do so the most
important thing is not the assets not
stocks bonds mutual funds or ETFs or
real estate or businesses or a Bitcoin
it's really you it's you the investor
that's going to make money so that's why
I recommend you know studying choose
your teachers wisely
don't listen to stupid poor teachers
please a poor teacher will teach you to
be poorer have a and the one the biggest
test the know but teach
repor has asked them if then a financial
statement and can I see our financial
statement you see everybody's asking
Trump which he'll never show is for his
financial statements or his tax returns
well Trump is never clear showing his
financial statements tax returns because
he doesn't pay taxes and that'll drive
the peasants while and Bernie Sanders
will be elected or Biden or whoever they
put up against them to the rich make a
lot of money that he's dead and they
don't pay taxes you can see that's not
fair it is fair because the laws are
fair for everyone but your education is
what changes like how you see the world
so if you believe I'm living debt-free
is Dave Ramsey says knock yourself out
if you want to cut up your credit cards
like Suze Orman says knock yourself up I
love my credit card but I have financial
education and I don't get in financial
that you know I invest my time and money
and my brain rather than listening to
poor teachers what made a conscious
effort to make sure I'm more productive
during the corona than before I think
why everyone's sitting down sleeping
that's the time they're rather done you
know so while people can't move they
frozen I'm throw it out and you're
working so the gallery is clicking
we got comedians in there right now in a
safe way and you know we get it in
and I just feel like everybody should do
that you know saying my bussiness
everyday so I don't wanna sound
redundant but I do want to remind
everybody so first thing when I wake up
you know actually see my notes looking
at scripts supporting looking skips I'm
planning my next moves you know I don't
think things are gonna be back to normal
and that's okay so I'm planning and
preparing for what the new normal is you
know it's time to strategize it's a plan
and to fight you know this is a war I
gotta figure out what the fight is the
mentality of anyone around me once you
get around me is to be a billionaire or
nothing and that's why you've noticed
the people that they talk about the
hip-hop that a billion is their
mentality that's consistent you know if
you think you can be a billionaire you
can be one you can understand you just
have to have a product to sell the
product got to be good you got to know
how to package it distribute it collect
your bread and do it all over again
consistently you know some people could
do it on their own and some people need
partners some people couldn't like you
know generate a billion dollars for
business some people that only billion
dollars just be really working but you
got to be doing something that people
would pay you a big and full I don't
know too many jobs that pay that you
know so for me you know being younger I
made a million dollars legally very
fairly quickly and I was like this is
kind of easy but I don't know about
everybody else it's just based on where
I was at the time it was like then I
made a million dollars this quick I
gotta get more and honestly I won't feel
I won't feel satisfied personally unless
I'm able to a treat achieve these dreams
oh my
you know and that's my dream is to do it
independently just so that I could pass
it to my daughter
and my sons and my other daughters you
know I the daughter you know that they
they're doing what they want you know
Ava wants the model right now am I good
but if she ever wants to run the company
she could I just feel like if you have
your not a purpose if you have nothing
to fight for
III wouldn't even understand that
existence you know I really wouldn't if
you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable continue to believe and I'll
see you there
it's a smoke screen for something that's
been going on for years